(keyboard clacking)
It's clear that something
is changing in Erie Harbor.
(birds squawking)
So why is
The Magic Arrow Chronicle
the only paper reporting
on this?
If the adults around here
won't do anything about it,
then I will.
Oh, my God, Hildy.
Shut up!
In season two, Hildy definitely
has a lot of clues to follow
with Richie, but also going off
into an environmental case.
Could you tell me if you have
anything on a strange event
last night?
Now, you know
how I feel about you,
but I can't be
your source anymore.
I love the dynamic and how it
shifted in season two,
that we're all working together
to find out what happened.
Hildy's relationship
with Matt,
and you get to see them
more as the journalist duo.
Walk me through your evidence,
all right?
Not what you're feeling,
not what you think,
but the facts.
Matt sees a lot of himself
in his daughter,
so it doesn't take much
for Hildy to ignite a spark
in his passion for journalism.
That's his story.
Izzy, gets to come and work
with me at the law firm.
She's sort of starting
to have a stronger sense
of the world around her,
and she's speaking out
alongside her sister.
Izzy, what do you know
about injustice?
Yeah, well,
I'll tell you what we know.
(cheering)
She gains all her confidence
this season as she finds out
who she actually wants to be.
Are you gonna tell her
something?
No. This is Izzy's thing.
There's a real love
within the Lisko family,
and also within
the friendships that we forged
in these two seasons.
We've definitely bonded so much.
This secret that Richie had,
it's not gonna stay buried.
I have a plan, dot, dot, dot.
I know that look.
So let's skip the part
where I don't wanna do it
and go straight to the part
where you convince me to.